what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we just got the very first teaser
trailer for the Marvels Captain Marvel
2. and honestly it looks pretty dang
good this is going to follow the story
of Captain Marvel Monica Rambo and
Kamala Khan aka Miss Marvel as every
time they use their powers they swap
places with each other this was hinted
to us at the end of Miss Marvel in The
post-credits Scene cabalicon goes to lay
on her bed until her mother yells at her
about not doing science homework her
bangle starts to glow and then all of a
sudden we see her teleport somewhere and
somebody else take her place and that
person is Captain Marvel Captain Marvel
looked at herself looks around and has
no idea what is going on and this is
where that trailer kind of picks up with
Kamala Khan and Monica Rambo swapping
places now with the release of this
trailer Disney has released a new plot
synopsis for this film which we're going
to go over first then break down the
trailer and if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on the Marvel's and so you can enter our
giveaway or a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends stuff
or some DC stuff the winner gets to pick
all you got to do is subscribe and leave
a comment down below now the new
synopsis for the Marvels that Disney
sent out this morning reads in Marvel
Studios is the Marvels Carol Danvers AKA
Captain Marvel has reclaimed her
identity from the tyrannical cree and
taken revenge on the Supreme
intelligence but unintended consequences
see Carol shouldering the burden of a
destabilized universe when her duties
send her to an anomalous Wormhole linked
to a Cree revolutionary her powers
become entangled with that of Jersey
City superfan molicon aka Miss Marvel
and Carol's estranged niece now saber
astronaut Captain Monica Rambo together
this unlikely Trio must team up and
learn to work in concert to save the
universe as the marbles now in one of
the post-credit scenes for one division
we saw a scene of a scroll speaking with
with Monaco rainbow stating that
somebody wants to talk to her and the
scroll pointed up now obviously they
were referring to Nick Fury and she has
been recruited by either Shield or Sword
whatever Nick Fury is a part of right
now so this trailer starts off in space
at a space station that they call Saber
now this is called saber but what it
really seems to be is the peak from
Marvel Comics and in the comics the peak
is a headquarters for sword that is in
space that orbits around the earth and
it actually looks pretty identical in
the comics to what we are seeing right
here now we were introduced to sword in
one division now sword stands for
sentient weapon observation and response
to vision and actually in the MCU Maria
Rambo Monica Rambo's mother established
sword she established this in 1995 it's
under the government and it is about
extraterrestrial operations using humans
originally it was supposed to use humans
as they went forward into the future
they started using Ai and Robotics and
sentient weapons however in one division
Monica Rambo ended up getting Powers so
it looks like Fury has recruited her for
several different reasons one her mother
was the founder of sword and sword is
responsible for protecting Earth from
extraterrestrial threats and now Monica
Rambo has powers so she gets to follow
in her mother's footsteps but she also
has power so she can protect the base
saber and she can also protect from
extraterrestrial threats now even though
this is labeled saber it is most likely
just the peak the operation for sword
and this is most likely where we saw
Fury in the post-credits for Spider-Man
far from home we know that Talos and his
wife were on Earth disguised as Fury and
Maria Hill and they showed us that Fury
looked to be kind of taken a vacation
except he was really just on the saber
headquarters now what's interesting
about this is we can see a lot of
different spaceships kind of floating
around it and in a very blink and you'll
miss it point in the trailer at three
seconds you can see a hex gate appear
these are what we originally saw in
Guardians of the Galaxy and this is how
some ships can kind of warp travel
through space so now it looks like Earth
is kind of playing nice with other
species in the Galaxy probably just the
scroll since Nick Fury is heavily
involved with the scroll but there could
be some other species involved in this
as well like the asgardians for example
could be using sword as well to kind of
jump to different parts and space
Guardians of the Galaxy is coming out
before this as well perhaps they have
something to do with establishing this
we'll have to wait and see on that but
it does look like they are becoming more
advanced and this is probably just to
kind of communicate with Captain Marvel
how she can go through different parts
of the Galaxy and then eventually get
back to the sword headquarters now in
the start of this trailer Monica is
outside and there seems to be some type
of anomaly that has appeared Monica
calls it the jump point and when she
comes in contact with it she uses her
powers and swaps places with Miss Marvel
Kamala Khan and they really lean into
the fact that she is a teenager in this
and I actually think it works really
really well because the second she
switches place with Monica Rambo she
immediately starts to freak out and an
energy surge sends her spiraling
backwards out of control moving towards
the sword base and you can just hear her
screaming oh my gosh oh my gosh she has
no idea what is happening all of a
sudden she's in space doing backflips
and then all of a sudden she sees Fury
now obviously Kamala Khan is a huge
Avengers and Captain Marvel fan She's a
nerd kind of like all of us which is
cool but that means she instantly
recognizes who Nick Fury is she freaks
out and goes oh my gosh Nick Fury Hi and
then we see Nick Fury freaking out
because he has no idea what happened but
she says is this an Avengers test
because she recently got her powers she
has recently used them for good so in
her head she's thinking that hey maybe
Nick Fury caught on to me he's been
watching me and maybe this is a test for
me to get into the Avengers so Miss
Marvel has swapped places with Monica
Rambo and it looks like Monica Rambo has
swapped places with Captain Marvel as
she finds herself on another planet
however it does show show her going
through another one of those hex Gates
so maybe this is a different scene not
her swapping places but she most likely
did swap places with Captain Marvel here
because as she lands on the planet we
see a bunch of Cree running after her so
clearly Captain Marvel was doing
something with the cree here and since
the new plot synopsis says that Captain
Marvel has sought her revenge on the
Supreme intelligence I am assuming the
cree aren't exactly her friends anymore
and then we see that as the other two
use their powers and Captain Marvel uses
her powers as well Captain Marvel's
Carol Danvers ends up in Kamala Khan's
room who again is a super fan of Captain
Marvel in particular she loves The
Avengers she loves the heroes but out of
everybody she loves Captain Marvel the
most so Captain Marvel sees all of this
stuff kind of dedicated to her and is so
confused about what is going on and then
something I gotta say pretty brilliant
happens I really gotta say this is very
clever by Marvel the song Intergalactic
by the Beastie Boy starts playing and I
love this song but what's really clever
about it is not only is is this going to
be an Intergalactic film but the first
words of the first verse of this song
are and we hear them play well now don't
you tell me to smile many of you might
have caught on to this and realized how
clever it was but if you didn't this is
a callback to the very first Captain
Marvel film where the first teaser
trailer for it came out a lot of people
came out and said Brie Larson needs to
smile more and this pissed Brie Larson
off because she said well you've never
said that to any of the male leads or
any of these Marvel shows they don't
smile and you've never told them to
smile but you're doing it to me she then
went on to photoshop a bunch of the male
characters posters into a smile she did
it for Doctor Strange Iron Man 3 Captain
America the Winter Soldier and this is a
direct callback because it's the first
trailer for Captain Marvel 2 essentially
it is Captain Marvel 2 just simply
called the Marvels so the first trailer
is a call back to the first trailer for
the first Captain Marvel film where they
told her to smile so this was very very
clever her so after this we see the
Marvel Studios logo pop up but then we
see it swap places with a different logo
very clever considering the three of
these women are going to be swapping
places with each other every time they
use their powers then we find ourselves
in Jersey City where Kamala Khan lives
we go to a door and Nick Fury and Monica
Rambo are at that door this is the home
of Kamala Khan and her family her dad
opens up the door Nick Fury says we're
looking for kamalakon kamalakon pops up
ecstatic because she already saw Nick
Fury in space and she asks did I get in
as in did I get into the Avengers am I
an Avenger now so clearly they ended up
using their powers again and Kamala Khan
has found herself back in her room and
back on Earth in her house she clearly
told her parents and her family what
happened as they are all gathered there
and Nick Fury does not look too pleased
at all and once we get inside the house
you can see that it's been kind of
damaged and you can also see what kind
of appears to be some guy in the living
room unconscious tied up this could be a
Cree perhaps Captain Marvel was fighting
a Korean was touching a Cree at the
moment or or perhaps Miss Marvel while
she was swapping places with Carol
Danvers got captured by Cree in which he
swapped back the cree went with her and
then she defeated it and her family tied
it up but from there Monica and Nick
Fury sit down and Monica starts to
explain that every time they use their
powers they swap places kamalacan gets
really excited to show Nick Fury and
Monica Rambo her powers and of course
once she does it she swaps places with
Captain Marvel Captain Marvel swaps
places shows up and she is clearly very
upset yelling not again her family
wonders where kamalakon is and they
State well wherever Captain Marvel was
and they show us that she was on a
cruise ship so Kamal Khan finds herself
on a cruise ship not knowing what to do
but luckily Captain Marvel before was
with goose the flirkin and Goose has her
back but also really freaks out Kamala
Khan at the same time because goose is
basically a full-on alien to her now
from here we get some really interesting
footage including seeing the villain of
the movie eventually Kamala Khan and
Monica Rambo are both with Captain
Marvel flying in some kind of jet could
possibly be an iteration of a quinjet
they go through one of the hex Gates and
perhaps Captain Marvel has such an
urgent mission that she just decided hey
y'all have to come with me because I
can't keep swapping places with you
going back to Earth so basically if
we're gonna swap places I need you right
next to me so I don't actually leave and
of course I think by the end they are
going to use this as an actual fighting
style as an advantage as every time they
use their powers they will swap places
they'll do that on purpose eventually
now we see kind of a new civilization
here A New World it does look like it
was filmed in Greece possibly the
circular building on the right seems
kind of as guardian although I do not
think this is Asgard or new Asgard on
Earth I definitely think that they're
off Planet here we see that there's some
kind of a celebration happening on this
planet we can see that Carol Danvers
Monaco Rambo and Kamal Khan are kind of
a part of the celebration and the people
here kind of seem like they could be
mixed species not just one species
living here but multiple different ones
we see some random scenes of Kamala Khan
using her powers Monica Rambo using her
powers we see kamalakon flying through
the air and Monica Rambo is jumping to
get her they eventually grab each other
and then we see Nick Fury on a base
saying Shields up now all of these
people behind him are wearing a white
outfit that was pretty much the same
thing that Monica Rambo was wearing so
these are most likely sword agents and
since he says Shields up they are
obviously about to get attacked by
somebody or are currently getting
attacked and then we see paxo jun's
character a very famous Korean actor
he's been in a lot of Korean dramas and
I recommend Eda one class if you have
not seen that and his character right
now is kind of a mystery he seems to be
some type of a leader of some alien race
that we don't really know about I do
believe he is playing a hero and I
actually think he could be saber now
saber was a human in the comics he was a
part of a group of militarized Chinese
superheroes and he was fighting against
the Mandarin and Iron Man actually came
to help them fight against the Mandarin
saber actually possessed two lightsabers
and in this brief scene that we see him
in we see him wielding sort of a weird
sword here now it's not a lightsaber and
he doesn't appear to be of Earth but the
fact that they named the peak saber kind
of makes me think here but who knows who
he is actually playing I do think that
the army that he has behind him are
fighting against the villain of the
movie who is going to be played by Zoe
Ashton now she is a Cree and the big
Theory out there is that she could be
the daughter of Ronan and we can see
that in this trailer she seems to be
carrying a very similar Hammer that
Ronan did carry now that was destroyed
by the Guardians of the Galaxy but
perhaps it was pieced back together or
perhaps it's some kind of sacred Cree
weapon and you can even see that a
person behind her to the right looks
extremely similar to Ronan now it's
obviously not Ronin Ronan has died in
the MCU at this point Guardians of the
Galaxy killed him and this is believed
to take place in present time so unless
we get some type of a flashback which
maybe we will I don't think Ronin is in
this I do think this is Ronan the
accuser's daughter and he was a part of
a sacred bloodline right his family was
known for being super intense and
showing no mercy so this is most likely
his daughter or somebody extremely close
to him very pissed off that he has died
and is now continuing the work of Ronan
the Accuser and what is extremely
interesting about seeing her in the
scene is if you look at her right arm it
looks like she is wearing the other
bangle to Kamala Khan's bangle now we
learned in Miss Marvel that there were
supposed to be two Bengals but they
could only find one at first they also
found the first Bengal on the arm of a
blue person believed to be a Korean now
that is pretty much confirmed since Zoe
Ashton's character is a Cree so it looks
like she's going to have some pretty big
Powers as well since she is wearing a
bangle and she'll most likely know how
to use it way better than Kamala Khan
knows how to use hers now the last thing
that we see of this trailer is like I
mentioned how the three of them are
actually using the fact that they are
switching places as a tactical advantage
to fight they are fighting a woman who
looks a lot like Carol Danvers AKA
Captain Marvel but is not because in the
final fight scene of this we see that
Captain Marvel is indeed fighting this
person as well now it could be somebody
who has shape-shifted to look like
Captain Marvel because it does look like
so it could be some type of a scroll
maybe a super scroll that's working with
the cree who knows but the big takeaway
from this final scene is that they are
now using the fact that they can switch
places with each other as a means of
actually fighting so they're actually
using it to their advantage and the last
thing that we hear is Kamala Khan
freaking out that she is now a part of
this team asking the other two oh we're
a team now and the other two are like
nope nope we're not a team not dealing
with this young teenager plus not to
mention Monica Rambo and Carol Danvers
are estranged now so they're probably
not on the best of terms so they
definitely don't want to be a part of
this team but it's called the Marvels
obviously by the end of the movie
they're gonna be like a little the
Marvel's family and that's it for this
trailer breakdown if you spotted
anything important that we might have
missed please let us know in the
comments down below and let us know your
general thoughts about this trailer I
genuinely thought it was a really good
trailer and hopefully the movie is
really good as well please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on the Marvels and
the MCU you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf